- Des centaines de personnes
venues rendre un dernier hommage
à l'ancien dirigeant
de l'Union soviétique.
Des citoyens de tous âges
ont déposé des roses
devant le cercueil ouvert.
La fille de Mikhaïl Gorbatchev
est assise tout près.
Aucun jour de deuil national
n'a été décrété pour celui
qui a reçu le prix Nobel
de la paix en 1990.
"Il n'y a pas eu de discours,
personne n'a parlé de ses
réalisations, de son importance
pour le monde. J'ai été surpris.
La cérémonie ressemblait
davantage aux funérailles
d'un homme important, mais pas
d'un personnage d'État."
Parmi les quelques dignitaires,
le premier ministre hongrois,
Viktor Orban. Le président russe
Vladimirrillait
par son absence. Il s'est
contenté de se recueillir
discrètement devant la dépouille
jeudi dernier.
Gorbatchov est arrivé
au pouvoir en 1985
et il a précipité, malgré lui,
la disparition de l'empire
soviétique, mettant fin
erre froide.
(cris de joie, applaudissements)
L'Occident le considère comme
une figure politique majeure du
XXe siècle, mais bien des Russes
jettent un autre regard sur lui.
Ils le voient comme celui
qui a affaibli leur pays
devant ldevant ldevant ldevant .
Néanmoins, beaucoup ont souligné
son héritage politique.
"Sous son règne, nous avons eu
un souffle de liberté,
uis reconnaissante de
nous avoir donné la "glasnost",
le pluralisme et la paix."
"Je suis pour l'ouverture,
pour le dialogue, c'est ce que
Gorbatchev a montré au monde."
Il a été enterré au cimetière
de Novodevichy, à Moscou,
aux côtés de son épouse.
Ici Mélissa François,
Radio-Canada, Mon